*intro* Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to YANDERE SIMULATOR
Now in the past few episodes that we've done of this
We've mostly just explored the depths of our own insanity
and what we've discovered is: we're pretty dang insane
es..Da....I said that good..?
Notice I didn't say intelligent, I just said insane
But, we're gonna explore further the-uh reasons by which we stand in order
What..?
we're gonna join a club
Basically
so, lets do that
and not make a fool of ourselves in any- welp that was the wrong button
*hides shame*there we go!
Alright, only boring girls
well *covers face* if there one thing I is, it's boring
eehm I'm not talking about me in the game I'm talking about Markiplier here
hAh.
oooh must be sweet, just like strawberries *weird laugh*
Hang on I gotta get my gear I forgot
Everybody happy? ok goOD!
hi ,welcome everybody, who the fuck are you?
I mean, I'm not one to question peoples normal morality
Hello! *HEUH PHHT*
Who are you? Are you my rival? (Maybe...)
Who the hell? I can't even talk to you. I can't even look at you
What are you doing? Who are you?
Hi! Ugh don't smile at like that, freaking weirdo!
Friendly but Strict, oh I thought that was the name, Kyoshi Taiso
Gym Teacher ..... GREAAAAAAAT
I don't know what you're doing here ugh don't give me that look
oH god stop checking me out like that (Thinks you hot..?)
I mean I know I'm gorgeous but frankly
you're creeping me out.
Where's Senpai?
(gasping and inhaling)  Hi~ how are you doing?
*INHALEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE*
a. YOU SMELL GOOD TODAY!!!! *SMELL*AAAAAAAAAA
that's a nice musk!
(Deep inhaling) HOOOOOkay I'm gonna go on my way now BAI SENPAI HAVE A LOVELY DAY AT SCHOOL
whatever it is you do while you're here
The first club that we're gonna join because we -we're preparing for the life of when we finally marry Senpai
And get to be able to provide for him as a wife
Not in the Counsler's office...
*Ha* that comes later
but (waiting)
RIGHT NOW while the marriage isn't on the rocks, we're gonna join the cooking club!
Hello robo! I would like to join
Yes, because the cooking club is the first way to win the hearts of all your friends!
And they are your friends,
no matter how much they scream they're not.
Anyway.....
Oh look at me! I'm freaking adorable!
With mah little bonnett
Ok so the good thing about this- place phone? steal phone?
Huh STOLE MY OWN PHONE! I DID IT!
It's little victories that I need to congradulate myself upon,
because otherwise, there's no joy and only murder! Hahaha-ha-ha
So, as you can see, I'm shoving a knife in a hot-dog
and turning it into something adorable
If you can see that, it's adorable
I've got a plate of liiitle-itty-bitty
octopi!
Huhuhu... they're soo cute!
Look at you!
Look at all of you!
AHHH... that's adorable..
OH! I even smile?!
What is this? I have emotions?? I was not made aware of these emotions!
What are these feelings fluttering in my chest?
Oh wait, it's a heart attack..
SENPAI!! ugh- I MADE YOU AN- oh...
shit
Can I not pick that up now?
Okay, well then...
SENPAI! Don't you want my lovely sausages....?
Damnit! SENPAIH!
*INHAAAAAALES*
(moans a little on the exhale)
GOODBYE!
*Ah* If I can just pick this up
ahh shit. OH NO!
GIVE ME THAT! I thought it was lost to the
winds. HEY BOOBS MCKENZIE!
There you are!
Heyyy, you're my ri-woah,
okay, this is a great view of the
locker. Oh boy, I would just gotta assume she ate it.
I mean, What else do we gonna assume, she
shov- never mind..ENJOY!
Again, I don't see anybody actually eating these.
It's gonna hurt my feelings.
and I might do something crazy!
if you dont take my food
and put it inside you...
okay
So as you can see, my reputation is sky rocketing
Im generally in a-
you better eat you little bitch! You say youre full!
Oh its ONE little hot dog whaddya gonna say
Oh, FILLED YOU UP?
IM GONNA START TO THINK YOU DIDNT LIKE IT
IM GONNA START TO THINK
YOU DIDNT LIKE IT AT ALL!
boy, your neck sure looks ripe
FOR THE SLICING!
I KNOW HOW TO DICE!
ill just pop your head off and turn it into an octopus
BRUH!
*Does the Markiplier Mating call*
(SCREECHING)
BREEEEEUUUUGGHHH-
What are you looking for? Some spicy sausages?
Ive got some!
You want so-
[character:] Get away! >:(
AHHOWHOW
*giggles* Why would you do that?
Im just trying to be your friend
[character:] Scram..
HELLO GURRLS!
Hows it goin?
Ya want some spicy dawgs?
[character:] Too close! >:(
Ohh jeez..
[character:] Get away! >:(
nohohoohohohhoh
[character:] Scram!
I will not!
I will give you-
[character:] Back off!
No! What about my doogers?
Aww, come on!
Theyre little octopuses
Okay, goodbye!
Well, Im gonna get outta here!
You all have a lovely day!
OR AM I?
I AM COMING FOR YOU GIRLS
I needed to get mah sausages
AH HAH HERE WE GO!
This is the Martial Arts club!
and the Martial Arts club allows you to win ANY fight!
[Character:] Welcome to the Martial Arts Club!
What brings you here?
[Character:] I'm sorry, but you can't be a member of two clubs at the same time.
[Character:] You'd have to leave your other club in order to join us.
(Mark inhales shakily)
(SCREECHES)
BREEAUUHGH
HAY IM LEAVIN YOUR STEWPID CLUB
*Robochick talking*
YEEAAAH
THANK YOUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUU
IM BACK BABEH
IMA JOIN!
[Character:] All we ask is that
you show up at least once a week!
Well, thats good!
because it seems to be exactly one week until I
fall over and die in this game!
or everyone else does!
One or the other
[Character:] FANTASTIC! You are now an official member of the Martial Arts Club!
HOOHAA!
[character:] I'm looking forward to
teaching you everything I know!
IM NOT
YOU SEEM LIKE A PRICK!
GOODBYEE
Im gonna change!
*gasps*
IM GETTING- OOH!
IM SO-
I was naked for like half a second
I-It counts!
Okay.
So what i can do now, is i can win
ANY FIGHT!
With a teacher or student!
and Im assuming that this means i can win a fight with those douchebags outside the school!
Im gonna show them what for, for not accepting
my spicy sausage!
Not eating the hot dogs...
Thats what i wanted to say....
Whu-heh wuh heheh?
I dont know about this!
WHUEH?!
Hello!
Ive got something to show you!
Besides mah sweet Kung-Fu moves!
I've gotta a knife!
*gasps* whoa
[Girl gang leader]: All talk and no action huh?
Yea apparently...
wHUUT???
[Girl gang leader:] You must have a death wish!
ahh maybe
Shwooohh
Shooohhhhh
Shwowowowowowowowowhoa
Shwo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wa-we-
SHWO-WO-WE-WA-wEOM-wOM-WO-WOH-
*thwack* OW! Whyd you do that?!
*giggles* Why did you do that?
I was trying to do something epic right there
Why did you do that?
YEWW SON OF A BITCH
Wu, Wu!
HA HAA!
uh oh..
*more giggles*
[Gym Teacher:] Just what do you think you're doing....?
uhm. I don't know. OW
Ya know, I thought
I was pretty sure
I was pretty sure that...
I THOUGHT!
That's what the...
Someone lied to me!
Im gonna sneak up on yew
Just lemme sliide on in here
Lemme just take a good
gander at the nape of your neck!
hehe! You'll never see me now!
Woah! Even more stealthy!
You can barely see me betwix her Legs
AH! I AM THE EPITOME OF STEALTH!
IMA JUST CRAWL UNDER HER DESK!
NO ONE WILL EVER SUSPECT
THE MURDEROUS RAMPAGER!
that is me!
here we go!
HA HA!
Nope- woahohhohohoho
[Teacher:] Just what do you think you're doing...?
i dunno
ya know i was just tryin a thing
ow! She plowed me right through the wall!
Ah well
I don't mind being sliced in the midsection if its at the hands of a beautiful teacher
[awkward neck scratch] ...i should stop talking...
Alright so that didn't work.
Apparently the Martial Arts club isnt as good as i thought it was.
Maybe its because i havent learned anything...
So im gonna go, and im gonna leeaarn me something
Unless that's a lie
(mumbling) then ...fuck em!
*rhythmic grunting*
Theres like a little fart happening everytime i lift my leg
*rhythmic farting*
(SCREEECH)
BREUGGHGH
Now that weve had a lovely day of doing club activities
You are ready to be the true Yandere that you always knew that you could be
Which is the point of this right?
Im not just dicking around here, im trying to prove something
show you education! Thats what Let's Plays are
arent they?
NoOoOoO?????
OH GAWD!
Hello!
Yes!
Let me!
Its the gaming club!
I have joined club!
and what join club do, is it gives you a whole slew of things here!
This one you can raise your stats that normally take a long time for you to learn in school!
But this one at the end here was apparently a mystery!
I dont know why- euh
dont mind me standing
just clipping through everything
*power up sound*
I don't know what that did!!!
But this ones the only one thats important! so i can boost my chemistry RIGHT AWAY
and i dont even need to wait around for it!
I dont even need to sit down for it!
and then i can go right to the chemistry lab
Which is
overrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
downstairs?
yeeah okay
So now
NOW
I just need to go to my class
HI TEACHER
and THEN
WHAT IM GONNA DOO
Okay, so now that everyone goes to lunchtime
all i have to do is wait around for
Boobs Mackenzie
to appear in the courtyard
trying to eat her very peaceful lunch
but little does she know
that I exist
and just like Senpai
who doesnt know i exist either
They won't see what's coming for them
for the case of Senpai, its true love
for the case of Boobs Mackenzie, its true death
both are good
except for the death,, that's not good
oh HAI SENPAI
OUUHHH
ARE YOU A PART OF THIIISSS?
AWW
HES SO DR- OH MY GOD
THE WAY YOU SIT DOWN AND LOOK AT THINGS!
hang on i gotta do mah hairs real quick
DON'T LOOK AT ME, I'M HIDEOUS
Course youd never say that, would you Senpai...?
would you?
heey OH
THERE'S SOMEONE IN MY PICTURE
I CAN JUST BARELY MAKE OUT THEIR BOOBS
I see Mackenzie...
I will devour you
uh...
YOU
SLATURN
i dont know why i keep using the term "bitch"
*Boobs Mackenzie speaks*
UH!
AH!
AAhh!!
YOU
YOU HARLOT
YOU DESERVE WHAT  i am going to watch
VERY CLOSELY
yea
this is exactly what i need to remember you by
OH SHUT UP
Take one picture of her and all you see is her boobs
(Kokona starts to choke)
uh oh
Uh Oh
Wa oh!
Well this dont seem good!
(Kokona gasping)
Huh!
Did something happen to you?
Oh No!
KARMA'S A BITCH!
Oh no!
Oh No!
Oh NO!
Its my victory crawl!
DONT MIND ME
so Senpai
as long as you dont look immediately to your left
How you doin?
OH HEY! HOW YOU DOIN-
UH OH
(Senpai:) W-what's up with her?
Oh dont mind me! Certainly not a murderer walking away from the scene of a criiiiiiiiime
hey teach.
Oh. Hi.
What are you doing?
mmmmm
yea POSE FOR ME
Thats good!
Over the dead body!
*incoherent babbling*
Oh, Look good for me!
Well, alright then.
I dunno what youre doing
Ohoho god
Stop dancing on the bodies of the dead!
Its awfully inappropriate
Ya know what,
Im just gonna let you do your thing
because frankly
i don't have the time or energy to deal with it!
So
Thank you everybody so much for watching
This has been Yandere Simulator
Theres a lot more clubs
and a lot more updates
that happen in this game very regularly
The developer has said that the next updates are gonna take longer,
because theyre gonna be more involved
so expect some cool things.
So let me know what you wanna see in the next episode
of Yandere Simulator
and as always,
I WILL SEE YOU IN THE NEXT VIDEO.
BUH-BYYEEEE
*outro music*